Salut, aujourd'hui je reviens avec une petite énigme
Un petit truc un petit peu rapide
Construite sur le thème de l'été, parce que c'est les vacances
Vous allez imaginer qu'il y a 8 personnes qui sortent d'un hôtel et ils vont à la plage
Et juste avant ils doivent aller voir quelqu'un qui à toutes les serviettes dans un seul bac
On va dire, un garçon de plage
Il a les 8 serviettes des 8 personnes
Sauf que le garçon de plage est nouveau et il sait pas du tout, à qui appartient quelles serviettes
Donc il va les donner complètement au hasard
Et l'énigme elle intervient tout de suite, elle est déjà là
Ma question c'est: "Quel est la probabilité, que parmi toutes ces personnes, 7 d'entres elles reçoivent, leurs vraies serviettes, la bonne serviette ?"
Je vous laisse réfléchir un petit peu à ça, vous pouvez quitter la vidéo si vous voulez et revenir plus tard
En tout cas, résistez à la tentation de donner la réponse dans les commentaires
Je sais que ça vous démange, mais essayer de résister !
N'hésitez pas à faire pause si vous avez envie de chercher parce que je vais donner la réponse dans...
3...
2...
1...
MAINTENANT !
La probabilité que 7 personnes, parmi les 8, reçoivent la bonne serviette est de 0%
Il n'y a aucune chance que ça arrive !
Alors ceux qui ont trouver ce disent "bah oui, c'est évident"
Mais ceux qui n'ont pas trouver ne doivent pas encore comprendre et ça doit vous agacer donc je vais vous dire pourquoi
Parce que comme ils sont 8, il ne peut pas y avoir 7 bonnes réponses
Si on le prendre à l'envers ça veut simplement dire qu'il ne peut pas y avoir 1 seule erreur
Si l'une des personnes n'a pas sa bonne serviette ça veut dire qu'il y a obligatoirement une deuxième personne
Qui n'a pas la bonne serviette
Il peut y avoir de 2 erreurs à 8 erreurs mais pas une seule erreur
C'est pour ça que la probabilité que 7 d'entre eux reçoivent la bonne serviette, est nulle
Il n'y a même pas besoin de savoir calculer s'était juste de la logique
J'espère que ça vous a plu, n'oubliez pas de liker la vidéo, vous pouvez vous abonner si ce n'est pas encore fait
Et moi comme d'habitude je vous donne rendez-vous, après demain, c'est à dire dans deux jours
CIAO !